- C'est plutôt tendu au
poste de contrôle qui sépare
la Moldavie du territoire
de la Transnistrie.
Un soldat nous a laissés entrer
après une série de questions.
Mais c'est en tant que touristes
et qu'avec nos téléphones pour
filmer que nous avons réussi
à pénétrer dans cette petite
enclave séparatiste pro-russe
où l'état d'alerte
est en vigueur depuis
la fin du mois d'avril.
Au-delà des barrages,
c'est le calme plat.
Difficile d'imaginer,
à première vue, que la guerre
pourrait s'étendre jusqu'ici.
"Mais l'Ukraine est à 2 km,
dit Dima, et ce sont des nazis, ils
peuvent nous attaquer n'importe quand,
ils l'ont déjà fait." Comme tant d'autres
tout ce que le Kremlin raconte
à la télévision.
La propagande russe fait partie
du quotidien ici et elle est
convaincante.
"Ce sont les Ukrainiens qui
tuent les leurs", dit Maria.
Même si elle a accès aux chaînes
du monde entier, elle se fie
aux nouvelles de Moscou.
"Évidemment, dit-elle,
c'est la Russie qui nous
nourrit, c'est la Russie qui
nous traite bien, nous sommes
des amis depuis l'ère
soviétique."
Ça fait plus de 30 ans
que la Transnistrie a fait
sécession de la Moldavie
avec le soutien de Moscou.
30 ans que la Russie, sans
reconnaître son autonomie,
la contrôle, avec plus de
1500 troupes présentes à l'année
longue.
La capitale, Tiraspol,
est à l'image des vieilles
villes soviétiques avec
sa statue de Lénine, la faucille
et le marteau, comme oubliée,
figée dans le temps.
"On est bien comme ça et on ne
veut pas la guerre, on veut
la paix", dit Galina sur un to
désespéré. Odessa n'est
qu'à 100 km à l'est.
Elle a peur et elle consciente
que son petit bout de pays est
au coeur des préoccupations
internationales, qu'on craint
de voir le Kremlin utiliser
ce territoire russophone
pour ouvrir un nouveau front
dans sa conquête de l'Ukraine.
Des craintes amplifiées par
ce général de l'armée russe,
qui a déclaré que le contrôle
du sud de l'Ukraine servirait
de couloir vers la Transnistrie,
où, dit-il, on observe également
des cas d'oppression de
la population russophone.
Quelques jours plus tard,
trois explosions secouaient
la région. Deux tours radio et
une vieille caserne militaire
ont été détruites. Moscou a crié
à l'attaque terroriste.
"On dit que c'est l'Ukraine
qui nous a attaqués avec
des drones", affirme Galina,
mais elle n'en sait pas plus.
Et c'est exactement le genre
de panique et de chaos queououor
pour justifier une intervention
militaire, selon Nikolai, qui
a tellement peur d'être mobilise
l'ont fait beaucoup d'autres de
son âge.
Nous l'avons croisé à
la banque, côté Moldave, où iln.
Il n'a que 18 ans et dit
que les forces séparatistes de
Transnistrie ont déjà commencé .
Il ne veut pas se battre,
ni contre l'Ukraine, ni contre
les Moldaves, avec qui il
cohabite en paix depuis sa
naissance. Des Moldaves comme
Lurie, propriétaire du garage
du village. Il dit qu'il prie
le bon Dieu pour que l'armée
ukrainienne barre la route
aux Russes.
Sa femme Ludmila nous rejoint;
elle est Ukrainienne.
Elle refuse de concevoir
une défaite de l'Ukraine.
"Ce n'est pas une option
envisageable", dit-elle.
♪ ♪ ♪
Elle se calme tous les jours
en chantant. C'était son gagne-
pain. Elle travaillait, avant
la guerre, pour une chorale
en Transnistrie, mais refuse
d'y remettre les pieds depuis
que son patron lui a dit que
l'Ukraine méritait ce qui lui
arrive. Les tensions redoutées
entre Moldaves et pro-Russes
gagnent ainsi du terrain.
Et avec chaque bombe qui
tombe, au loin sur Odessa,
la guerre se rapproche d'eux.
Luire et Ludmila espérent
le mieux, mais se préparent
au pire. C'est dans la cave
à vin qu'ils ir
en cas d'attaque.
Ludmila dit que sa fille
lui demande souvent...
pourquoi un pays grand comme
la Russie aurait besoin de
l'Ukraine ou de la petite
Moldavie?
(chant)
Les semaines passent,
la guerre continue, et elle
ne sait toujours pas quoi lui
répondre.
♪ ♪